here now with reaction Florida Attorney
General Pam Bondi you know I know it's a
small minority Pam it's very small what
is the case of water cost four bucks
five bucks right maybe they want to
raise the price of dollar mm-hmm but a
hundred by the way belt yeah best
monologue I've ever heard you do
especially on September 11th it was
pretty beautiful what you just said you
know Sean yeah water and I'll tell you
what Amazon's done though Amazon these
were third-party vendors I was on the
phone with Amazon corporate they brought
in their entire team in Seattle they
started of course they have their
automated system they brought in a team
of people and started manually scrubbing
it they've already banned 500
third-party people from going on Amazon
and selling so there's a lot of bad but
there's a lot of good yeah we've seen
convenience stores gouging you know
locally 7-elevens were it ridiculous but
they were franchises corporate 7/11
called me and then they donated to make
up for these button we're going to go
after their franchises by the way the
bad ones but 7-eleven overall the 10,000
stores were great they've donated one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
the American Red Cross and $100,000
$100,000 to our state tomorrow Home
Depot starting to rain on us right now
tomorrow Home Depot they are sending a
convoy of trucks Sean 80 trucks down to
South Florida waters are going to be 297
a case plywood generators extension
cords so we've seen a lot of good and
I'll tell you what if you're gouging in
our state we're going to go after you
and Governor Rick Scott has saved so
many lives he said to say hi Sean by the
way because he got the people out of our
state I'm so blessed to have him as our
governor I'll be honest and it was just
refreshing I mean we've seen when
hurricanes can become a disaster you
know for example Katrina but here's what
here's what I want I if you go back to
Ferguson Missouri if you go to Baltimore
and all these people all the looting and
all that went on there we have video of
these people we can identify them they
never use
the video and these people end up
getting away with it is that going to
happen in this case are you going to
search out every like we could see their
faces right there we know who they are
Oh Sean all of our sheriff's are all
over it our National Guard has been
fully deployed cannot thank them enough
federal assistance we've coming in
thanks to president Trump our state we
are going to be in good shape if you're
looting from our citizens we're going to
go after you if your price gouging in
our state I'm going to go after you and
I will shame you on national TV I will
call you out and and you know we're
going to now see people coming in from
other states trying to sell generators
for $1,000 to take care of you know to
hurt people in need who have babies at
home and no power and but but for the
most part people the Red Cross has been
amazing people are working so well
together one thing if I can mention to
your viewers assignment of benefits
people now are going to start coming to
your door wanting to repair your homes
they're going to start wanting to
because you say they're contractors make
sure they're licensed do not assign your
insurance benefits over to any
contractor talk to your insurance
company first that's one of the big
scams we're going to start seeing as
well as charity scams and you and I run
earlier with Reverend Franklin Graham
who has a phenomenal charity as well but
you know we're going to start here from
the bad charities come in as well that's
right Samaritans first Red Cross org all
the good ones Pam please go after these
people you know what there's nothing
worse and I know first of all mine art
nothing worse than doing this Thea
fellow Floridians and thank God most
people are not like this but those that
are I hope you throw them in jail all of
them
alright Pam thank you and well I got
storefront thank you thanks Sean what
okay thank you